Okay folks.
Thank you for getting your numbers in
and I think almost everybody had their
numbers and I think I think one or two
people might not have but get your
numbers in this
by the end of today so I don't want you
to lose five points.
And if you've done the project and you
don't have the numbers, yeah? The final
project obviously is due by 5:00 so many
of you already I I see the projects
coming in.
So if you're still holding out
get it in again. And if it's 5:05 I'm
not going to be hard-nosed about it so
get it in as soon as you can
because I need to start grading.
So it's all about me and so you know
that's basically it.
Um what we're going to do today is
actually twofold. One is I'm going to
take your numbers and take you through
the class and use it as a way of talking
about all of the different things we've
talked about in the class.
And I also want to kind of complete one
part of the last session I did not get
to value control. We kind of laid the
foundations but I want to put the bow on
the value control.
So let's get this process on the road,
right? I don't know whether Yogi Bear
actually said all the things he's
supposed to have said. I'm convinced
that he and Confucius basically people
make up stuff and claim Yogi Bear has
said it can Who's going to contest it,
right?
It ain't over till it's over but I think
that's a good way to think about you
know valuation. It's never quite over.
Things keep happening.
So let's go back to the beginning. I
said in the start of this class there
were three ways you could put a number
on an asset.
And I'm going to describe the three ways
perhaps
in less um academic terms than I did
then.
In intrinsic valuation what do you do?
You try to make your best guesses
about growth, margins, and reinvestment
and hope they all come together into a
value that you can actually put your
money behind.
So intrinsic valuation is all about
understanding businesses and cash flows.
In pricing you look at what other people
are paying for similar things
and I'm going to put quotes on similar
because clearly that you know as you saw
defining a peer group is almost an art
form. You can make your company
underpriced or overpriced depending on
how you define that peer group.
And the third is if you have a company
where there's a contingency, something
that can cause
cash flows to increase in the future. It
doesn't It's not something you expect
right now. Right now you don't think
it's not viable. There's an optionality
there. Whether it's an um
biotech company, whether it's a natural
resource company, there might be
optionality but you use it selectively.
It's not going to be around for most
companies.
So that lead in let's go back at the and
and start with that basic structure we
started intrinsic value with.
I mean you break it down it's one
equation, right? Value of an asset is
the present value of the expected cash
flows on that asset. It's amazing how
much time we've belabored that one
equation because everything we do is to
get numbers for that equation.
So you start with the cash flows from
existing assets which might be a lot if
you're looking at Coca-Cola and not very
much if you're looking at a young growth
company and that's where your current
financials are most helpful in getting
cash flows from existing assets.
And then what? You're on your own,
right? Because now you're in no man's
land. It's about the future. You've got
to make your best estimates
and that best estimate includes how much
you value growth at and growth can add
value, destroy value, do nothing value
depending on how much you reinvest to
get that growth. And the only place in
valuation you can show risk is in your
discount
and you apply closure with a terminal
value which we can use a perpetual
growth model as we often do but keep
open the alternatives of a finite growth
annuity if you have a limited life
company or maybe even a liquidation
value if it's a privately owned
business. That's it. That's all of
intrinsic valuation.
And of course in the specifics of an
individual company you can take all of
those inputs and boil them down
to four drivers of value. Three drive
the cash flows, revenue growth,
margins, and reinvestment. And in a
sense by keeping it simple you force
yourself to make everything you look at
go through one of those three levers.
Yeah? Sina just valued Apple. What do
you use as revenue growth?
I use 16%.
16%. Already you're at the upper end of
the spectrum, right? 16% growth for a
company the size of Apple means we
better be upgrading our iPhones every
time a new upgrade because that's
effectively what it boils down to,
right? It's no longer new products or
Apple services. The iPhone carries the
company.
He's left the margins at 35%. Sky-high
margins.
And he still comes up with the value $40
below the stock price. Can happen.
Revenue growth, margins, reinvestment.
With Apple the tricky thing about
reinvestment is the reinvestment is
going to take the form of R&D and not
necessarily manufacturing and the tariff
shock might make that reinvestment
larger because now you've got to move
your factories out of China into India,
from Vietnam to somewhere else. Those
things will all play out.
And in terms of risk you basically have
this cost of capital. We can use beta as
in risk premium so that ultimately
that's the risk of operations in the
company.
But there's one other measure of risk
that you've got to factor in, not so
much for Apple
but for younger companies, companies
with a lot of debt, which is there is a
chance of failure. Something we almost
deliberately ignore in discounted cash
flow valuation but you have to
explicitly factor it and if any if
anybody says why don't we just build it
into the discount rate? Mit, what's the
response to that? Because that's often
what I hear from people in valuation is
if there's failure risk why aren't we
pumping into the discount rate? Why
isn't the discount rate a good vehicle
for failure risk?
You need an answer to this because you
will get pushed back on what What's this
failure risk thing? Why can't I just
increase the discount rate?
How high can you make your discount
rate? Let's say you could fail in the
next three months. How high does your
discount rate have to be to factor that
in? It has to move towards infinity,
right?
Discount rates don't give you much room
to bring in enough failure risk to
factor in the true This is why VCs crash
and burn when they try to do what they
call discounted cash flow valuation
which is really a forward pricing
discounted back at a made-up discount
rate
which can be 40, 50, or 60%. They're
hoping it somehow captures failure risk.
But it's a terrible way to bring in
failure risk.
Ultimately everything in valuation plays
out through those.
So
I've used this before but I'll bring it
out again. When When you go back and
look at your company
use what I call the valuation triangle
to assess your company. And we'll use
this triangle to talk about great
companies, average companies, and bad
companies. The three sides of the
triangle. One is growth. Obviously you
want high growth if you can
but it's not often your choice. The
second is profitability, right?
And the other two are the risk and the
reinvestment you need to get this
company going.
What do great companies look like? They
have high growth.
They have high margins, low
reinvestment, and low risk. So if you
think about the valuation triangle for a
great company.
Most companies though there are
trade-offs. What does it mean to go for
higher growth? You've got to give up
something on margins.
To go Sometimes to grow you've got to go
to riskier markets which pushes up your
risk.
Business is full of trade-offs and we
don't factor those in we miss the entire
point of value.
So as you look at this triangle this is
basically what's underlying your
valuation. You could take your revenue
growth, your margin, your reinvestment
and if I compared it across the people
in this class I'm going to just getting
a sense of how many of you value. So
Sina's forecast for Apple are those of a
great company.
But great companies
can be bad investments.
Right? Because they can be priced too
high and that's basically what they do.
So I'm going to take what you found
and add the caveat that I did in my
corporate finance classes is these are
your numbers so if you screwed up on the
numbers it's not my fault.
Right?
So I'm going to show you what you found
and take from it what you will about
what you see in the cross section.
So let's start by looking at the
companies you valued.
Remember I did not prevent you from
valuing a company that other people are
valuing and I'll talk about in a minute
why I don't care.
Five of you valued Palantir in my
corporate finance class.
It was the number one
SS company in my undergraduate class.
Eight people are valuing Palantir.
Clearly, it's a mood of the moment,
right?
Four valued Netflix because you got you
didn't pick a company until week three.
You were watching Netflix and said, "Let
me pick Netflix. That might be the
best." It shows up every single
semester, right?
And then you had three with Boeing. And
in my undergraduate class, six people
Boeing, Starbucks.
Basically, because they're this this
this defining point, right? Where
essentially you're saying, "Can they be
recouped? Can there be value here or
not?" They're interesting from that
perspective. And there were seven firms
where at least two people valued the
same firm.
Now, here's why I don't care.
I pulled up Palantir.
And I don't know who this Palantir
Technologies but you might have to
either fix your numbers or something or
I don't Is there another company that
I'm not aware of that's the Cuz clearly,
that doesn't fit, right? That $3 price
is not I would love to buy Palantir at
$3.
I have a feeling it was really late at
night and or you were drinking too much.
No. So, the that whole line doesn't make
sense. So, let's take that line out,
right? And if you're the person who did
that line, go fix it in the master sheet
cuz I don't want to put it into
posterity on my webpage, right?
But the other four are all in the
running. You're saying, "Why the price
is different?" Because you valued your
companies at different points in time.
And I tried to get you all to get to
Friday as your decision point. Because
there's really no point valuing a
company as of the middle of April. So, I
would have bought Palantir. Did you? If
you didn't, then let's not talk about
it, right? So, the prices are different
because of different points in time,
which I understand. Um
Philip just told me that this is a
mistake. So, the $7.27
is not quite that low. But he doesn't
like the company anyway. But the key is
there are four sells or three sells. I
won't again I'll ignore the last one and
one hold.
There are companies you can get buys and
sells at the same time because you could
look at the same company, look at the
same numbers, and come to different
judgments. Clearly, everybody else still
thinks Palantir is either a sell or at
best a hold.
Now, I'm in your camp because I have a
limit buy in Palantir and it hasn't hit
yet, which tells you where I stand in
the game.
But clearly, it's a company with a lot
of disagreement but what the future
would deliver.
So, here's what you found.
So, what I did was I took your DCF
value.
I took the price.
And I took the price over DCF. So, the
way to read this is the median company
in this class was overvalued by about
28%. The price was about 28% higher.
There were 35% of the companies in this
class were undervalued. 65% were
overvalued.
You found more overvalued than
undervalued companies.
Now, I'll show you what the what the
numbers look like over time. I mean,
there there is this canard that
intrinsic valuation is conservative.
That somehow you're more likely to find
companies to be undervalued. That's not
true. It varies across time. It varies
across markets. This semester, more of
you found your companies to be
overvalued than undervalued. And some by
pretty significant amounts, right? 62%
of the third quartile and you can look
at the 80th, 90th. So, you're going to
get companies that are overvalued by 80,
90, 100%.
Here are your most undervalued companies
based on your DCF.
So, the way I'm getting the ranking is I
divide the price by the value and the
lower that number, the more undervalued
you are. So, Betsson, which I'm not
familiar with. Who Who did Betsson?
No, not here.
Again, as I said, take the second one
off the list. So, I'm not sure what to
do with that one.
And then you've got Kepler Weber.
Anybody here?
Okay.
You like the company? Yeah.
What does it do? I'm not familiar with
it.
Post harvest solutions. What What
solutions?
Grain storage, drying, and elevators.
It's a logistics company, basically? No,
it's basically a manufacturing company.
It's a manufacturing company, okay. And
but they provide like turnkey solutions,
basically. So, they Okay. All right. Why
did you pick them?
Well, I like them. I stumbled up on them
sometime ago. Okay. Made some research
into what the company is doing, how the
market is growing. And what I found is
that
um you could
Right now in South Are you actually
going to buy the company?
I would If I could, I would.
Okay. The reason I ask is every semester
for the last 30 years, I've picked one
company on this list to buy.
But I have a condition, which is I'm
buying only if you're buying.
Not I might buy. So, I'm not ready to
buy because he said, "If I have the
money." So, that's kind of an
abstraction.
If you're buy So, if you're on this list
and you're buying,
let me know because I will buy that
stock. It goes into a separate portfolio
that I call my valuation class
portfolio, right? Which I track over
time. So, I'll show you what it what's
done over time. So, this These are the
most undervalued companies according to
your DCF valuations. Huge range of
companies. No particular theme or
pattern, which is good, right? If you
get seven oil companies you undervalued,
then you worry about the 2024 numbers
driving that decision. So, the fact that
they're diverse across markets, across
No.
Now, obviously, I like BYD as a company.
I did have that limit buy that kicked
in. I hope you're right that it's
significantly undervalued because then I
would benefit from that undervaluation
as well.
As for the overvalued companies, I go to
the other end of the spectrum.
And there's Philip right there up there.
Most Among the most overpriced.
No, I'm sorry. I would sell it either
way. You'd sell it either way. So,
and so basically, you can
Madison Square Garden, I think anything
associated with the Dolans should
automatically be overpriced. I don't
think I care what it's priced at. So,
that's the list of most overvalued.
Ashima?
Zomato?
You want to make a case?
What do you think?
I I did the other one. Like mine My
price was 188.
Oh, yours was very You did some So,
there were two Zomatos. You Yours was
not in the most overvalued list then.
But
but not by as much as that, right?
So, these are your most overvalued
stocks
across the sample.
So, as I said, I've been tracking your
undervalued and overvalued stocks for a
long time. And one of the things Now,
clearly, this takes a while. If you're
If you're doing intrinsic valuation, you
need time as your ally. So, I really
can't do spring 2024, 2023. So, I've
tracked going back in time. So, you can
look at five Basically, got These are
all semesters. So, I have the updated
numbers going through I think 2015. I'd
give you at least five or 10 years for
it to pay off.
There's a Those are your undervalued
stocks, the blue, right?
There's the S&P 500.
There's your sells. So, at least
in a rough sense, your buys beat your
sells and the buys beat the market. But
I didn't get too excited about this cuz
there are no transactions costs and
other issues brought in. But if you're
running a fund that and you deliver
those returns, you'd be a hero, right?
Active investing doesn't pay off that
much.
So, I did take a closer look
at your winners and losers. What caused
those excess returns?
On average, you get it right about 80%
of all buy recommendations do beat the
market in the long term. But so do 45%
sell recommendations. So, basically,
there's it's noisy. It's not a you know,
it's not a perfect It's not 100% buys go
up and 100% sells. Now, the average
return by recommendation about 4% higher
on an annualized basis the market,
right?
The excess returns on buy
recommendations come more from the small
and emerging market companies in the
group than from the from the large cap
companies, which kind of makes sense,
right?
But here's something that I think you
always find in successful portfolios.
Most of the returns, those excess
returns, come from one or two big
winners.
It's not across the board.
Like 1999,
somebody told me to buy Apple.
Right?
It That's a great holding if you think
about the returns it makes. And that I
think is a general truth about making
money in active investing. It's your big
winners that carry your portfolio, which
also means that if you panic and sell
off those big winners somewhere early in
the game, there goes your active
investing payoff. So, it's kind of this
balance between holding on long enough
and not holding on too much that seems
to determine it.
And those stocks that were undervalued
and underpriced You know what I mean
underpriced? You compared the pricing to
the price?
Were far more likely to do well than
companies with just undervalued and over
So, some of you got mixed messages,
right? Your valuation came into the
undervaluation. Your pricing was
overpriced. Those tended to do less
well.
The point The reason I make that point
is often you go into a camp. I'm an
intrinsic value person
or I'm a pricer. And my argument is
maybe you should look at both, right?
I'm an intrinsic value person. I believe
in intrinsic valuation but I like it if
the pricing is also working in my favor
cuz one of those two I don't care how I
make money. Whether it was the pricing
that got fixed to the or the valuation
that got fixed.
So, that's the intrinsic valuation. I
want to take a brief tangent before I
look at your pricing to talk about the
value control. In the last session, we
talked about any company you can value
twice. A status quo value, which is the
existing management continuing to run
the company. And most of you in valuing
a companies did a status quo value.
So, Tim Cook continues to run Apple and
those are the things that are driving
the valuation. But, we also talked about
how you can change value.
And fundamentally to change value, you
got to change one or more of the inputs
that go into valuation. So, I'm going to
try to take everything I know about
fixing a company and put it into one
bit. You can try to increase your cash
flow through existing assets by doing
what? Cutting costs, being more
efficient operations, having less
maintenance capex. That's the first
lever. Second,
when you look at growth, it's a mixed
message. If you have a good business,
you can create value by reinvesting
more. If you have a bad business, you
can create value by reinvesting less.
On the cost of capital, anything that
you do that lowers your cost of capital,
including changing the mix of debt and
equity and matching up your debt to your
assets, increases your value.
And to the extent that you can build in
corporate strategy that lengthens out
how long you can grow and how much your
excess returns are, you can increase
value as well.
Now, your potential to change value is
going to vary across companies. The
better managed a company is, the less
potential for there is to change value.
The worst managed a company is, the more
you can fix.
That at the heart of it, I said, is the
value of control.
So, I want to revisit that because it's
actually a very interesting way to think
about lots of things in markets.
Now, normally when you talk about
control, what does it talk when you talk
about acquisitions, right?
But, is control an issue in every
company?
Let's say you take the Boeing company or
let's take Intel right now. It's a
company where the top management has
been in flux. You got a new CEO.
Is the value of control already built
in? I'm going to argue that the value of
control shows up everywhere. It shows up
in publicly traded companies because
people build in expectations that that
there will be change in management. Of
course, shows up in hostile
acquisitions. It shows up in how you
price voting and non-voting shares in
companies. It's actually a great tool to
think about lots of things in investing
and valuation you run into.
So, let's think about the value of
control. There's a There's a change in
value that you get from running the firm
differently versus a status quo. But, to
do that, you have to change the
management of a company. And what are
the things that drive that? One is are
there restrictions on takeovers?
Remember, the most the bludgeon for
changing management is a hostile
acquisition.
If I don't let that happen, I've taken
away one of the mechanisms by which
management can change. Much of Europe,
until you got to the last decade, you
couldn't do hostile acquisitions of
companies. You just could not raise the
capital.
Now, that's starting to change. So,
that's the first thing. Second is to the
extent that there are rights and no
different voting rights for different
class of shares, that affects my chance
of changing management.
Third is to change the management, often
you need to have access to capital.
There's a reason
activist investing has a much stronger
foothold in the US than any other
market. It's You can go out as, you
know, as Bill Ackman and raise 5 billion
to take over a company. That's tough to
do in many markets. And finally, it's
easier to change management if you're
looking at a small company than if
you're looking at a Microsoft. You might
not like the way
Microsoft is run, but what are you going
to do? $3 trillion is a lot of
So, I'm going to use that to kind of
talk about lots of factors that come
into the value of control.
Now, when you think about it, of course,
the the likelihood of changing
management, you really talk about
corporate governance, right? That's
basically at the heart of corporate
governance. What is the chance that I
have of changing value? Those rules ebb
and flow over time.
Even in the US, right after the '90s and
the scandals that came out of the '90s,
you had Sarbanes-Oxley claiming to fix
the corporate governance problem by
making directors more independent. There
are many emerging markets that have
actively tried to improve corporate
governance to attract foreign
institutional investors coming in.
Second, you know, active in activist
investing, even in the US, ebbs and
flows.
There are periods where you have a lot
of activist investors and periods where
they go away. And hostile acquisitions
remind managers that there's somebody
looking over their shoulders. All of
those things affect them.
So, I'm going to use the value of
control to talk about four different
four different scenarios where it comes
into play. I'm going to argue that when
you look at the stock price of any
publicly traded company,
embedded in the stock price are
assumptions the market is making about
whether management will change in that
company.
So, what you're seeing in Boeing's stock
price is not the status quo value, but
some expected value given who's running
the company today and given the
possibility of change.
Second, when you're looking at hostile
acquisition, you talk about the value of
control. Clearly, this comes into play
because you could potentially pay up to
that number as a premium
and essentially get a bargain because as
soon as you fix it, you get the extra
value.
Third, I'm going to argue that
understanding the expected value of
control can allow you to differentiate
between voting and non-voting shares
or even high voting right and low voting
right shares. Let's think about the
direction. If you have voting shares and
non-voting shares in a company, Leon,
which one should trade for more?
Um
The voting ones, right? Because you get
the right to make change.
But, by how much? You know how bankers
estimate by how much? They look at
voting and non-voting shares that trade
out there and say, "On average, voting
shares trade at a 7% premium." Then they
apply to every voting share, which makes
no sense to me.
So, we're going to talk about what is it
that makes voting and non-voting shares
trade close to each other for some
companies and very differently from each
other for other companies.
And finally, in the context of private
company valuation, we never talked about
this.
When you buy 49% of a private company,
a privately owned company, you'll pay a
lot less
than if you buy 51%.
Why? Because with 51%, you run the
company. With 49%, the existing owners
run the company. It's called the
minority discount.
Think of it as a flip side of a control
premium. You're actually discounting
value because you can't change the way a
company is run.
So, let's start with the first one. When
you look at any publicly traded stock,
you could argue that what you observe as
a market price is a weighted average
of what the value of the company is run
by the existing management and what the
value of the company would be run by
somebody more competent with
probabilities attached.
So, if you found Boeing to be overvalued
with a status quo valuation,
it might be that the market is a saying,
"Status quo, you're right. Boeing is
overvalued. It's not worth this much,
but if somebody else ran the company, it
could be worth 25% more."
You're saying it's purely subjective?
Absolutely. Markets operate in a
subjective space. You could argue that
every publicly traded stock
has that expected value. You see the
implications of this? Let's say you're
in a market where corporate governance
is dead in the water.
What's going to happen to the value of
the market price of every company?
It's going to go to the status quo
value. So, badly run companies will be
priced as badly run companies. Well-run
companies will be priced as well-run
companies and that's the end of the
game.
Let's say in that market, you now
introduce rules that allow for
management change.
Which companies will benefit the most
from those corporate governance changes
in terms of market prices?
The badly run ones because now you've
introduced a likelihood of change in
that company. The next time you see a
major corporate governance reform in an
emerging market,
I would load up on the badly managed,
badly run companies in that market
because that's Do a Do run a portfolio.
Don't do it in the worst managed, worst
run company in the entire market. You're
asking for trouble. Pick a bunch of them
and hope that change works in your
favor.
Hostile acquisitions, you know we know
the rules. We value control in
acquisition. All we do is you take the
target company and we revalue. With
what? An optimal debt ratio for the
target company.
Not the the acquiring company's debt
ratio, but the target company. Maybe
with better investment policies. Maybe
better growth, you know, investments.
You come up with the value. You come up
with an extra number. And in this case,
you know, I valued Blockbuster last week
at like $5.12,
right?
And the optimal value came up with We
came up with was about $12.47 per share.
Basically, it was trading at $9.50.
The extra $2.97,
you can argue is for the value of
control.
But, if you pay the entire $2.97 up
front as a premium,
you're essentially going to get a fair
value investment.
What I'm trying to say is if you value
control in a company and you're doing an
acquisition, you want to keep some of
that benefit for yourself.
How much is debatable. You're not going
to get 100%. You're not going to get
even 50%. But, even if you can get 20%,
go for it because you're doing the work
of fixing the company and you should get
some benefit from it.
So, as you look at any company, you can
argue you can always value control
whether there's an acquisition or not.
So, let's talk about valuing voting and
non-voting shares. A few years ago, I
valued Embraer.
Dagmar, you valued Embraer this You came
up with a sell, I think, or a buy?
Hold, okay. So, you chickened out, but I
will talk about that later, right? So,
it was a hold. That's a company that
I've been fascinated with, interested in
for almost 20 years. This is a long time
ago. I valued
Embraer twice. Once with a status quo
value, 12 and 1/2 billion dollars,
and once run differently.
And got a value 14.7 billion. Embraer
has two classes of shares. They're
called common and preferred, but really
voting shares non-voting shares. The
preferred shares are just no common
shares without voting, right? They're
called preferred in in Latin America.
So, they're not like preferred shares in
the US, which are more like bonds.
There were
242.5
million voting shares and almost 477
million non-voting shares. So, Leon's
given me a sense of direction the voting
shares should trade for more than the
non-voting shares. I was interested in
whether I could come up with how much of
a premium.
So, let's start by looking at how many
shares are outstanding out there and
let's think about the rights you get. If
you're a non-voting shareholder,
what do you have?
No rights. You can't change the
management. In my view, you're stuck
with the status quo.
So, here's what I'm going to do to get
the status quo value. I'm going to take
the status quo value and divide by the
total number of shares outstanding,
voting and non-voting, and what I get is
a value per share. $17.38
is what I'd pay for a non-voting share.
Essentially, I'm stuck with the status
quo value.
If you get the voting shares, what do
you get? You get a right, a chance at
least to change the management.
You take the expected value of control,
14,700 - 12,500. I think the chance of
changing management here is pretty low.
Why is it that, Mark? Why is it so
difficult to change management in
Brazil?
It's a company they're golden shares
from the It's a government It's a
government-controlled company for better
or worse, like Petrobras. You want to
change, you've got to get really
desperate. It's not zero. I mean, even
Petrobras eventually hit bottom, you
know, and had to find a way out of
there. It's not zero, but it's low, 20%.
You can see if I put 0% in there,
what's going to happen? The value of
control goes away. My voting and
non-voting shares would trade at the
roughly the same price. Here, there is a
chance of changing management, 20%. You
apply it to the expect the value of
control. That's your expected value of
control, but then divide it by just
the voting shares.
They're the ones who control that. And I
get a value per share of 19 19.19 reais.
Yes or no?
Would that work if you're just buying
one share? It's not enough to change it.
Like, if you own 51%, I get it, but
would it still apply if you Because you
piggyback on somebody else doing it,
right? As a group, you gain the I'll
tell you when I mean, I learn learned
this the hard way. I used to own shares
in Ambev a long, long time ago when it
was a standalone Brazilian beverage
company.
And one day, this Brazilian brewer this
Belgian brewer called Ambev decides to
acquire Ambev.
So, I'm a shareholder. I'm pretty happy
to see the news. Somebody is trying to
acquire it. That's always good news,
right? To be a target company
shareholder.
And they were paying a 30% premium. I
said, this is good.
3 months later, the merger actually got
done. I looked at my actual shares and
they didn't change at all.
You know why? Because Ambev just
acquired the voting shares.
They paid a big premium for the voting
shares. The voting shareholders got a
70% premium.
They left the other shareholders us. In
some countries, you can sue and try to
get your money, but in Brazil, you could
not. The voting shareholders essentially
got almost all of the value added. So,
even if you're a small voting
shareholder, they needed your shares.
They didn't need mine.
And this is probably an extreme way to
think about voting and non-voting shares
because the extent that minority rights
get protected legally, the difference
should narrow.
But the implication still remain, right?
In a perfectly managed, perfectly run
firm, what should be the difference the
difference between voting and non-voting
share prices?
Close to zero. The worst managed, worst
run a firm is, if you get a chance, go
back and look at Facebook class A and
class B shares over their history.
For much of the early history, the
shares traded roughly the same price.
Why? Cuz Facebook was viewed as a very
well-run company. And then you get to
2018, 19, and 20, you see the two start
to diverge. That's, of course, the
metaverse fiasco. They've come back down
again, but it's a good way to think
about what does the market think about
this company? Let's look at the
difference between voting and non-voting
shares. You can do the same thing with
Google class A, class B, and class B
shares over time. At least you can get a
sense of what markets think about the
company and its management by just
looking at that difference. So, better
managed companies, the less you care
about voting rights. The worst managed
companies,
there are Canadian companies where there
are actually there are two voting shares
and two million non-voting shares. And
the two voting shares are held by the
guy running the company. And there are
cases where the difference is a
hundredfold between getting the voting
shares and the non-voting shares because
the company is so badly run
that he So, when you think about voting
and non-voting shares, also think about
the value of control because it plays
out in the background.
Any questions? Right?
I was Yes. Um hey, like so with Google,
for example, the founders and direction
have owned large chunk of shares. Of the
voting shares, not the total shares,
right? I mean, Mark Zuckerberg only owns
only 13% of Facebook shares in terms of
pure share count. If this were a
pre-2004
company where US companies not have two
classes of shares, Mark Zuckerberg would
be a 13% shareholder, which means that
if enough people gathered together, they
could remove him as CEO.
That's why Elon Musk is exposed,
right? Cuz Tesla doesn't have two
classes of shares. He doesn't control
enough shares to actually control the
company.
But Mark Zuckerberg, with 13% of all
shares, has 57% of the voting rights.
That's what creates the dysfunction here
is you control 50% plus of the voting
rights, which gives you control with far
less than 50% of shares.
And the same thing's true for Google as
well because Google has three classes of
shares. Class A has 10 times the voting
rights of class B, and class C has no
voting rights at all. So, it's almost
like you Now, so when you look at
companies, that comes into play as well.
And the more entrenched the founders
are, the less the expected value of
control. Right? It gets really difficult
to move them out.
Finally, let's talk about minority
discounts. Let's say you value a
privately owned candy company, and you
come up with two values. 1.6 million of
the company run as is by the existing
owner,
and 2 million run by somebody more who
knows the business or runs it better,
right? So, you got two values.
So, I'm going to make two offers to you.
First is I offer you 49% of the company.
And I keep 51%. I'm the one running the
company now. What's the most you're
going to pay?
49% of the status quo value, right?
1.6 million.
I offer you 51% of the same company.
Just a 2% difference, but now you run
the company. You could pay up to 51% of
2 million. Not You might not pay the
whole amount.
That difference, that 2% discount,
translates into a 20 to 30%
loss in value. That's a minority
discount.
So, when you look at minority discounts
again in private company valuation,
people use rules of thumb. But if you
truly want to estimate a minority
discount, go back to estimating value
twice, status quo value, optimal value.
It's an incredibly effective way to
resolve some of those big challenges we
often face in appraisal and valuation.
Now, you go back and look at what we've
done in this class. It's pretty basic,
right? Cash flows, discount rates. I
mean, the issues we've run into are
estimation issues. They're not
theoretical issues.
And if you're a consulting firm, this is
a problem. Why is it a problem? If what
you're doing is simple,
you can't charge millions of dollars
for doing it.
And after all, if you do if you can show
a company how to do intrinsic valuation,
they can do it themselves, right?
Revenue growth margin They actually know
more about getting those inputs
than you do as McKinsey you're paying.
So, over time, what have consulting
firms done? They create these usually
acronyms
that they claim are magical.
They say, "This is We found a new way to
think about value." And effectively,
they push that out there because then
you can't do this on your own. You need
our magic bullet to do it.
And usually, these these measures are
simpler than a discounted cash flow
value. That's one of the selling points.
Discounted cash flow valuation, you've
got to think about the future. You've
got to think about cash flows and growth
and risk, and that's messy. Instead,
focus on this acronym we give you, and
everything's going to be okay. Come on,
it's appealing, right?
The advantage is the simplicity. The
disadvantage is whenever you use these
simplistic measures, you're making
implicit assumptions
about all those They don't go away.
I'll give you two examples.
In the 1990s, there was this firm that
was New York-based called Stern Stewart,
run by these two guys, Joel Stern and
Bennett Stewart, who could sell a
refrigerators to Eskimos.
I mean, they're the great salespeople.
But basically, they sold this idea
called economic value added. I'm going
to give you the definition of economic
value added, and you tell me whether
it's mind-blowing because they claimed
it was mind-blowing.
They took the difference between return
on capital and cost of capital. It's
amazing, right? Nobody had thought about
it till they did.
So, that's an excess return measure
that's been as old as time. They
multiplied it by the capital investment.
They converted it into a dollar measure.
And they said, "This is all you need to
run a company is you just have to
increase your EVA, economic value added,
and you're going to be more valuable."
You have enough ammunition now to take
that sales pitch apart.
So, tell me all the perverse ways you
could increase your EVA next year while
making your company less valuable. What
You can go first.
I Ways of So, this is a perverse
exercise. I'm Stern Stewart, I tell you
to increase EVA next year, and I tie
your bonuses to it. So, your actual
compensation tied. How do you increase
EVA? What are the three numbers here?
You got return on capital, you got cost
of capital, you got capital invested.
Either reduce the
capital expenditure or you Oh, let's
stop there. How do you reduce capital
invested? You play accounting games.
Remember, these were the '90s, if you
lease something, it didn't show up as
part of capital invested.
So, you could make capital disappear,
push up your return capital and cost of
capital, and make it look like you were
making money. Companies did that. They
basically took things they owned and
leased them because it made their
capital invested go down and make the
return on capital go up. What else can
you do?
Anybody?
Matt, any ideas on how I can rip off my
shareholders on making my compensation
go up?
Can I increase my return on capital next
year while costing myself growth in the
long term? I can steal from future
growth, right?
I mean, basically, what I would do is
I'll go for high returns next year,
short-term projects that deliver 12%
returns, and give up on long-term
projects that make 10%.
Worth a lot less to me in value terms,
but because you're so focused on EVA,
I'm going to
And there's a third game, which is the
risk game that I can play. I'm look
You're looking at the spread over the
cost of capital, right?
Is a 3% spread on an 8% cost of capital
worth less than a 4% spread on a 10% I'm
don't expect you to work out the
numbers, but basically, two things are
changing. I'm looking at the spread, but
I'm also raising the cost of capital.
A higher spread at a higher cost of
capital could be worth less than a lower
spread. I'd rather earn a 2% spread on a
5% cost of capital than a 5% spread on a
10% You work out the numbers.
The fact that your spread over your cost
of capital went up doesn't make me more
valuable.
By the middle of the 1990s, half of all
of the S&P 500 companies had Stern
Stewart as a consultant.
And many of them were basing
compensation based on EVA.
A horrifically bad exercise because
everything that you expect to go wrong
did go wrong.
Thank God, eventually, people caught on,
but Stern Stewart got wealthy along the
way. You know, the one thing they did
though is what's the what's the
definition of return on capital?
Come on, you know by now. What's in the
numerator? After-tax After-tax operating
income divided by book value debt plus
You see, this is simple. So, you know
what they had to do? They said they made
64 adjustments to those numbers to
compute the return on capital. Why did
they do this?
Cuz then you couldn't do it on your own.
So, who did they who did you need to
come in and do it for you? Stern
Stewart. This is something remember in
consulting, you want to make this an
exercise where they need you to come
back every 6 months because without you,
they're lost.
I won't call this a scam because that
might be too loose a word, but clearly,
this is an exercise in extracting value
from people
and giving them wine in old bottles.
There was Stern Stewart.
There was another outfit called Holt
Associates, Chicago-based company that
came up with this measure called CFROI.
Sounds fancy, right? But they put the CF
in there. Why? Cash flows are better
than earnings.
It was basically, you know, in fact, you
could if you think of EVA as analogous
to NPV, CFROI was like an internal rate
of return. So, they said, "We will tell
companies based on their existing cash
flows what kind of IRR they're earning
on their existing investments."
Sounds fancy, but all they did was they
came up with a measure of gross cash
flow from the most recent year. So, they
played some games with inflation and
depreciation, and divided by the
invested capital, and say, "Your company
has 11% CFROI. That's good because it's
higher than your cost of capital."
Again, it's a shortcut. You're saying
you don't have to deal with growth and
all that other stuff in valuation, we'll
just give you a metric that you can
focus on.
Now, it um it that outfit pushed this.
Eventually, Credit Suisse paid, I think,
$250 million to buy CFROI from Holt
Associates.
And then they gave it to their equity
research analysts to use.
And after a while, they realized nobody
was getting any meaningful numbers from
doing it because it made no sense with
many growth companies even try to
compute that number.
So, what I'm trying to alert you to is
there will be people out there who claim
they've come up with a new and different
way of doing intrinsic valuation.
There's no such thing.
The basics are the basics, no matter how
much you dress it up, eventually, you
have to get back there.
So, the bottom line is the value of a
firm is a function of its cash flows,
growth, and risk. It's true with
simplistic assumptions about those, I
can make it into a metric. Because if
you focus on this, everything's going to
be okay.
But I'm holding a lot of other things
constant. If I let you play with those
other things, you can deliver a higher
number on my metric while making me a
less valuable business.
So, let's get back
to what you found. So, intrinsic
valuation, what is it? 65% of your
companies were overvalued, 35% were
undervalued.
Let's revisit that four-step process for
thinking about pricing.
Define.
Now, Anacona Copper might know what the
P/E ratio is, but I'm not sure I do. So,
when you talk about multiples, make sure
that you are talking about the same
multiple that I am. You could be talking
about EV to EBITDA, I could be talking
about EV to EBITDA, we could be talking
about two very different numbers
depending on how it's defined.
Right?
And make sure it passes a consistency
test. What does that require? Numerator
has to be matched up to the denominator.
Remember again why we net cash out of
the numerator when we do EV to EBITDA.
What should I ask you? Why do we I I
sent Phil kept asking me.
Gabriel, why why do we net cash out of
the numerator when we do EV to EBITDA?
Because we already included it.
We already included it. What's in the
denominator?
EBITDA. The interest income from
Go back to that test anytime you look at
a multiple. What's in the numerator?
What's in the denominator? Have I
matched up right? Is it consistently
defined? Is it uniformly estimated?
Tough to estimate,
but you got to kind of push for it.
Second stop, play some moneyball. You
have no excuse for using rules of thumb
anymore. The data is there.
You have access to Capital IQ at least
till the end of May, download the whole
damn thing into a into a spreadsheet.
It'll work for about 3 months, and then
it'll stop working cuz the data will get
old.
But, you know, there are I I will send
you some links to online sources of
data. There's this a site called Koyfin,
if you get a chance. It's a few hundred
dollars a year for a subscription, and
you can download the data just like It's
not as complete as Capital IQ, but it's
good enough.
We have the data, download the data, do
all the standard statistical stuff, but
most of all, put that histograms
on a paper. It'll tell you how symmetric
or asymmetric the distribution is, and
how much you can trust averages, and
when you should be moving to medians.
Define, describe. Third step, remember,
if it's an equity multiple to see what
variables to control for, all you need
to do is go back to a basic equity
valuation model, stable growth dividend
discount model. If your algebra is weak,
stay with stable growth models, right?
Because the algebra will work out. If
it's an enterprise value multiple, go
back to an enterprise value model.
You're ultimately making assumptions
about cash flows, growth, and risk when
you ask me to pay 50 times revenues or
30 times earnings or 10 times book value
for a company, back out what those
assumptions are. And then you get to
that final step. Remember, the peer
group you pick will determine the
pricing you get. Pricing is always a
conditional statement. You're saying,
"My company is cheap given these 15
other companies I'm comparing it to."
And if you change that peer group, you
could get a very different answer.
In fact, many of you I've pushed you
into using my market regression. For
most of the market regression gives you
numbers you don't trust. That's okay,
but you're asking a different question,
right? In your analysis, you're saying,
"Given my peer group, is my company
cheaper or expensive?" With a market
regression, you're saying, "Given how
the market is pricing these companies,
is my company cheaper or expensive?" So,
different question, you could get a very
different answer.
Right? So, there's the drivers of
multiples. It's a reproduction of a page
you've seen a couple of times. So, when
in doubt, you can keep this page, but
you can derive it yourself. It's
actually better if you do it yourself so
you feel you own what drives multiple.
Cuz this is going to tell you what
questions to ask when somebody says,
"This company is cheap cuz it trades at
half of revenues
or three times earnings or five times
EBITDA."
So, more uh guide to what questions to
ask before you decide that something is
truly cheap. Most things that look cheap
deserve to be cheap. That's something we
always have to start with. You're trying
to figure out something that looks cheap
that doesn't deserve to be cheap.
So, here's what you use.
Notice a preponderance of EV multiples.
Over the last 20 years, this graph has
shifted. When I first started, used to
get half of all companies with P/E
ratios. Now, people are kind of kept
creeping up the income statement.
Why? Because desperation, I guess.
Right?
You're a money-losing company, you know.
What else can you Julian's valuing
revenue. What choice you have but to use
revenues, right?
Yes, Phil.
So, obviously, there's this big movement
with EBITDA, but if you look at
the Warren Buffett of the world, they're
they don't believe in it. It's about the
earnings at the end of the day. When
you're looking at the
But but what's in the Warren Buffett
portfolio? It's got under the list,
right?
In a sense he's focused on mature
companies. you can get away with using
price earnings ratios, right? Price to
book ratios. So, I think if you decide
that that's where in the life cycle
you're going to focus your investing,
then equity multiples work fine. PE
ratios, price to book ratios. But if you
want to give any growth companies a
chance to be in your portfolio and use
PE ratios, you're already going to kill
them even before they get started,
right? Money-losing company. Who's going
to buy
a Reddit if you use a PE ratio? So, I
think that, you know, especially, you
know, you're going to notice a lot
written about Warren Buffett, the things
he did well, the things he did badly. I
mean, there's a lot to admire about the
man. I mean, he was he He had a set of
beliefs about markets that were very
clear.
He stayed true to those beliefs and he
didn't kind of bend to whatever the
market was doing. That's very difficult
to do.
But at the same time, he did stay within
what he thought was his safety zone,
which is mature companies. Yeah. But if
you're if everyone's shift No, I mean,
but the majority are shifting to looking
at EBITDA multiples
as like the key metric moving forward,
even if the company could potentially
not have strong earnings and just You
could write a fundamentals, it could
still be
But I would argue there's a problem with
pricing in general, right? No matter
which metric you pick, I could pick
apart the weakness in that multiple.
What do When we do pricing, what are we
doing? We're just saying, look, we don't
want to go through the trouble of
forecasting future cash flows, growth,
and risk. We It's the equivalent of what
consulting firms are doing. We'll give
you something simple to focus on.
Pricing comes with its own issues. And I
think with EBITDA multiples, you're
pointing to one of those issues, which
is you can have a lot of EBITDA and
never figure out a way to actually
deliver cash flows because it's before
capex, before taxes, before all of that
other stuff.
A lot of big infrastructure companies in
terrible businesses look really cheap on
an EV to EBITDA basis. And that's why I
pushed you ask the right question.
What's your return on capital? What's
your reinvestment rate? Because once you
ask those questions, you're less likely
to fall into that EBITDA trap, right?
I did compare your DCF value to your
pricing.
So, you know what I mean, right? You
have a DCF and
And the way to read this is the median
number was 87%
With the median company, the DCF was 87%
of your pricing. So, your pricing was
higher than your DCF.
And there were some companies your
pricing was way through the roof
relative to your DCF, right?
42% of your companies, your DCF value
was higher than the pricing.
And again, I want you to remember that
because I heard people say, I don't
know, at least I got at least a couple
of emails last week saying there's
something wrong. My DCF value is is
higher than my pricing. Cuz we've almost
been trained to think that if you do a
DCF, it must be lower than the That's
not true. 42% of companies, the DCF was
actually higher than the pricing. True,
58% the pricing was higher than the DCF.
And in terms of pricing results,
remember it put it was for the DCF When
we did the DCF, the average company was
overvalued by about 26%.
Here, the average company is overpriced
by only about 5%.
And you can see why, right? Why with
pricing are you going to get roughly
100% price and value?
What are we doing in the pricing? We're
saying, given how other stocks are
priced, how much should I pay for the
stock? It's almost as a relative
statement, you're unlikely to get the
26, 30. You're going to get some
companies look overpriced and some look
underpriced, but basically you're going
to kind of steady out around the 0%.
Mhm.
So, 44% came out as underpriced, 57% 56%
came out as overpriced.
And here were your most underpriced
companies. Mhm.
Matt, you got a You weren't up there.
How strongly do you feel about that
pricing?
Did What What did you find in the DCF? I
I found So, undervalued, right? Are you
buying?
Um yes. You should talk to Chris before
you do it, right?
Chris is Chris is a doctor. So, one of
the problems with anything to do with
medical stuff is, let's face it, there's
so much we don't know, right? So, I
think that Chris did a What What do you
surgical intuitive surgical, right?
Right.
So, he found it overvalued. And you know
what? I'm not touching it. If the doctor
says this thing is not going to work.
So, there are some areas where I don't
enter in and pharmaceuticals and
biotechnology is one of those.
Especially young biotech companies. I
say, you know what? It might look good,
but I don't know enough about this
space. It's some It's But it's also a
place where you get the competitive
advantage. If you invest the time and
the resources understanding that space,
you could probably get a benefit over
others
in that space.
But these are the most underpriced
stocks. Whole range of different
multiples. The first one,
I'm not even sure You know, the DCF was
a negative value, which means on an
intrinsic value basis, this company's
underwater, but the pricing makes it
underpriced, which is, I guess, the
reason there's a hold on it rather than
a buy because you're getting mixed
messages. And you can see there are
quite a few mixed messages. There's
another sell down here. In fact, there
are three sells, I think,
in this list. Stocks that look
underpriced, we're putting a sell
because your DCF pushed you in the other
direction.
For the most overpriced,
mhm.
And
That's not yours, right, Phil? First
one?
So, Palantir makes the most overpriced.
So, somebody else found Palantir to be
overpriced as well. Yes.
A lot of So, there are two Palantirs
showing up there. A lot No, which makes
it bad news that I'm thinking about
buying Palantir, but no.
But those are the most overpriced.
Finally, there the a subset of you did
try option pricing. And remember the
conditions you need to apply option
pricing. You need a lot of debt and you
need to be money-losing that made it
restricted. I think in your In this
class, over 15 companies where there was
real options attempted value company.
You start with the DCF value as your S
and then you build on top of it, which
means you get a premium over intrinsic
valuation. That's the bottom line. And
the average premium that you came up
with by using an option pricing model
was about 45% over what you got from
your intrinsic value model.
So,
with if your company meets the
requirements for an option pricing
model, there's some real value in
actually trying it out and seeing
whether your company is being traded as
an option. And there's nothing wrong
with investing in an option. If you do
it as a portfolio of options and you're
realistic about the fact that 80% of the
time these companies are going to crash
and burn, but the 20% of the time when
they go up, they make up the difference.
The last week,
you got done with your value and your
pricing.
And I got quite a few emails saying, I
don't know what to do now.
You
You know what? I understand. You know,
you You know, you're getting to a point
I say ask you to buy or sell or hold.
And I I think you you know, almost
everybody would will fall into one of
three camps. You said,
I've come up with a value and a pricing,
but I'm not sure yet.
Be honest. I mean, when you finish it,
you say, I'm not sure yet. I need to
collect more information. I need to get
more
I mean,
if you let that stop you, you will never
actually make a decision because you
think this uncertainty is going to get
resolved, there'll be another
uncertainty down the
The second is you try this and you say,
you know what? This wasn't that easy to
do. Maybe the market's not such a bad
thing to follow. So, there are amazing
number of people who come out of this
class saying, I'm willing buying index
funds for the rest of my life. I'm never
investing in a company. And that's okay,
right? And it's You know, nobody should
be forced to be an active investor.
And the third is,
and this is what I think allows me to
make a decision. If I had to put all my
money in one company, there isn't a
single company in the world that I feel
confident enough that I'll be able to
pull the trigger.
But if you're adding an investment to
your portfolio,
it takes a lot of the stress off, right?
You don't have to be right on that one.
You just have to be right on average.
And that's what I want you to think
about is getting to a point where you're
able to pull the trigger because you're
letting the law of large numbers work in
your favor. And that's tough when you
first get started. Why is that?
Cuz you don't have any stocks in your
portfolio. How the hell do I do my first
stock? No.
Is there a way to to do that, though?
Because otherwise, you're never going to
get started. That first stock is going
to be insanely difficult to actually
buy.
Yes. I have a few 500 I In fact, that's
my suggestion to people. Buy an index
fund, not because you've given up, but
because you want to get to a base so
that next investment
is not going to change the way you live.
Right?
And that's prudent. It's And people
think it's Oh, it's a sign of weak. I've
got an MBA. I shouldn't be investing in
the index funds. No, that's not the
lesson I want you to take out of this.
There's nothing wrong with building a
base before you start taking that
investment. And then as you add on, you
can start to reduce If you feel you are
comfortable with your stock picking, you
can reduce your index funds and move
into the stocks
you want to add on.
But trying to do it all on that first
stock is not just dangerous. It's going
to be really difficult to do because
psychologically, you're saying, what if
I'm wrong? And that's a good thing to
think about if all your money's riding
on that one stock.
So, finally, I asked you buy, sell, or
hold.
You can see See breakdown.
I think there were 35 buys and 68 sells.
So it's about a 0.61 buy. You're
definitely not sells at equity research
analysts, right? There's 9 to 1 buys to
sells. It's amazing how when you have to
invest your own money, you become a lot
more cautious, right?
And there were about 12% holds. I keep
trying every semester to make the hold
zero,
but it never quite is there. You get
really close and you know,
it's 10 12% holds.
So I've tracked this number over time
and pick out of this graph whatever you
want because I've looked at the buy sell
sell and the ratio going back to 1999.
So when that So there's two two axes. So
let's focus on the black line. That's a
buy to sell ratio. In 1999, the buy to
sell ratio was a was about 0.95, which
means for every 100
sells, there were 95 buys. So that ratio
has varied over time. I've squinted and
tried to see if I can get any market
timing advice out of this. I have a
tough time finding any market timing
that I can do because I'd love to tell
you that when your buy ratios are high,
the market goes up in subsequent periods
and your buy ratios it doesn't seem to
follow that pattern. It just varies.
Much of it is driven by the mood of the
moment, which is right now. I understand
why there are so many sells because
we've been in a semester where
everything here is, you know, good or
bad markets, about the way the world is
going. That's going to find its way into
your buys and sells.
So is there a right way to put a number
on an asset?
Depends. It depends on who you are and
why you're doing things. It depends on
what you're trying to put a number on.
If your what you're trying to put a
number on doesn't have cash flows, you
shouldn't be trying to do an intrinsic
valuation. So if you're spending six
months trying to value Bitcoin, come on,
give up. There is no cash flow. It's got
to be priced. It's a either
cryptocurrency or a crypto collectible.
Neither can be valued.
So your cash flows matter. Second is,
you know, to the extent that, you know,
how marketable is this because that's
going to be whether you can get a
pricing for it, whether there are other
things being priced. And it also depends
on who you are as a person.
Now early on I said if you have a long
time horizon, you're a much better
candidate for intrinsic valuation.
And I think I mentioned one of the
biggest advantages Warren Buffett
brought to the table during his years as
a successful investor was in investing
insurance company money.
And insurance company money doesn't
panic.
And doesn't panic, it gives you an
immense advantage during crisis to be
able to take a position that cuts
against the market
cuz you have the true long time Most of
us claim to have a long time horizon,
but the truth is
the world imposes its constraints on
your time horizon, right? So if you have
health problems, your time horizon
shrinks.
If your kids have to go off to college,
your time horizon shrinks. So time
horizons are often determined by the
circumstance of your life.
It also depends on why you're putting a
number on something.
Many of you are going to go work for
banks in M&A.
What are you doing valuing things? Your
job is pricing.
If you want to do a pricing and then do
a reverse engineer a Kabuki dance DCF,
by all means do it.
Right? You know all the levers to use,
right? You will hide all your biases
well, I hope.
No? You So don't make it a 5.83% growth
rate in perpetuity because then I know
exactly where you went.
Hide it someplace I can't even know
where to look.
Right? Because that's basically what
will separate people who are good at No,
so if you have to do pricing, don't
don't be defensive about There's nothing
wrong with pricing if your job is to
price things.
And finally, beliefs about markets come
into play, right? Because you With every
one of these approaches, you're making
an assumption about market mistakes
and how markets correct their mistakes.
And
there's no way we all agree on that on
that So
it's a process. Start thinking about how
markets make mistakes. Be willing to
revisit that hypothesis as evidence
comes in.
But finesse it because until you get
that, you can't still start building an
investment philosophy. You cannot have
an investment philosophy without a
well-thought-through perspective on
where markets make mistakes and how they
correct themselves.
So I'm going to ask you a question I
started with I think I asked in session
two or three when you still hadn't done
your valuation and pricing.
And I said, if you had to pick an
approach
to use in putting a number on an asset,
I said, would you go this kind of cash
flow valuation, a pricing, or would you
believe in efficient markets?
I'm going to let you revisit that
question and I want you to think about
whether you your mind has been changed
over what you've had to to kind of work
with when you Anybody change their mind
came in as true believers in intrinsic
valuation now are a lot more skeptical
or the reverse?
No, everybody's mind was pretty much
where it was to start.
But something to start thinking about,
right? Because until you actually do an
intrinsic valuation, it's an
abstraction.
Right? And then you sit there and try to
estimate growth and margins and
reinvestment for Palantir. Philip, I'm
sure has a very different perspective on
intrinsic valuation after having had to
value Palantir than before because
I mean, you say things like, who the
heck knows?
I'm making up crap as I'm going along.
You know, it's it's only when you start
to get your hands on the same thing with
pricing.
You know, when you do an equity research
report, it looks so neat, right? There's
a multiple, there are these 21
companies, and then you sit with capital
like you and say,
how the heck did they come up with the
21? I'm starting with 55, which 34 do I
take out? And already you can see how
much gaming there can be in the system.
And early in the class, I also asked you
what comes more naturally to you. Are
you more of a storyteller or a number
cruncher? Remember that question?
I think the very first slides I asked
you that question.
So if you fell into the storyteller camp
then, here's what I hope this class gave
you.
Much more confidence. So if you are a
storyteller, I hope you at least get the
sense of what margins try to capture for
you and returns on capital. You should
be able to do that.
You should be a little more disciplined
in your storytelling. You might believe
in a great company, but a great company
doesn't automatically deliver higher
revenue growth. You have to have some
constraints.
And finally, I hope you don't let
bankers intimidate you if you're a
storyteller.
They pull out EBITDA multiples, you can
pull out EBITDA multiples as well.
In fact, yesterday I was looking at this
two-page uh
document that one of the clubs had put
out and questions that you get asked for
the as first-year MBAs for the
internship.
Right?
Like, you know, where do you you know, I
think one of the questions was uh about
EV to EBITDA multiples and you know, and
I was coming going to come up with a
counter list of questions you can ask
the banker to see if they truly
understand what EV to EBITDA multiples
is. You might not Don't try it out
because you might lose that job, but
keep it aside because now many of them
have such a surface-level understanding
of what they claim to be masters of that
if you dig a little deeper, you very
quickly realize. So ask, what what do
tax rates affect your EV to EBITDA? But
never had to think about it. And they
do, right? And basically by pushing
back, you can get a sense of how deep
that that that
If you're a number cruncher like me,
I hope,
and this is a tougher task I set up
front,
that you get enough confidence to be
wrong.
Cuz you are going to be wrong.
You got I mean, you know, you you're
trying to forecast the future. How can
you not be wrong?
Yeah?
And little more imagination in your
storytelling.
Don't feel so constrained to have to
explain everything with a data point or
an equation.
Cuz you can't. There's some things
you have to estimate and say, trust me,
this is what I think for the company.
This is what I'm basing it on, but I
can't quite make that link.
And when confronted with storytellers,
have some patience.
Right? Basically, the fact that you
speak different languages doesn't mean
you can't have a conversation about the
value of a company. Both sides will
emerge stronger
if number crunchers listen to
storytellers and storytellers listen to
number crunchers.
If I were to summarize the class, then
I'm not big on advice.
First is, it all comes back to basics.
How many times have you seen that
revenue growth margin reinvestment risk
page, right?
And if you look at my blog posts, I
always go back to that. When I'm looking
at tariffs, when I'm looking at
inflation, I mean, because it allows you
to think about big issues and say, this
is where it's going to show up in my
valuation.
Every few years, somebody will say, the
basics don't matter. The fundamentals
have changed. No, the fundamentals
always remain the same. You can be dot
com, you can be AI, but ultimately, it's
got to show up through the cash flows,
the growth, and the risk.
Second,
look at the big picture, right? It's
easy to get lost in the details. So I
know how much time you spent coming up
with the cost of debt for your company.
But if you have 3% debt ratio, does it
really matter?
You can almost estimate any cost of
debt, you're going to end up with
roughly the same cost of capital.
I'm not picking on you, but in a sense,
that's one of the things I wanted to
work on is when you think about where to
spend your time, you want to spend your
time on the things that matter
rather than the things that are
distractions. And that's
the biggest decision you make in in
valuation and investing is what are the
things that matter? Let me focus on
those things.
Third, you'll be surrounded by people
who've have working 40 years and will
tell you that they have a lot of
experience. You shouldn't push back.
They know what an EBIT uh
should be for a company.
Investing is one of those things where
you can be your experience actually is
not going to give you that much of an
advantage over some In fact, it might
put you at a disadvantage because you
think you know more than you do.
Fourth, and I think this comes out of
the earlier talk about story
To me, the scarcest quality in investing
and valuation is imagination.
Everybody wants tight rules. They want
to get to an answer. Now, being creative
and
imaginative is really tough to do
because when you're wrong,
you're going to be visibly wrong, and
people don't want to be wrong.
And here are my final two points. Now,
keep your perspective. So, only
evaluation.
If your response is, "What else is there
in life?"
I would seriously suggest some spiritual
counseling.
And
I remember you know, about 15 years ago,
at the end of one of these classes,
second-year MBA comes up to me. She was
a history major from Yale who came back
for an MBA.
And if you're a history major from Yale,
you come back for an MBA, you take the
strategic MBA route. You know what that
is?
Pick all the classes with the word
strategic or sustainable in the title.
You could spend 2 years without ever
seeing a number, get an MBA, and move
on.
She ended up in this class, which is not
a strategic or a sustainable valuation
class, just a valuation class.
She turned out to be pretty good. So, at
the end of the class, she comes up and
she says, "I never thought this would
happen, but I have a job as a sell-side
equity research analyst."
I said, "My condolences." No, I said,
"Congratulations."
And she said, "I'm really scared."
I said, "What are you so scared about?"
She said, "What if I'm wrong?" I said,
"Be glad you're not a brain surgeon."
Brain surgeon is wrong, somebody dies on
the table. You're wrong, what's the
worst that's going to happen? Somebody's
going to get a little richer. Somebody
else who's going to get a little poorer.
Just make sure that somebody's getting a
little poorer is not you. That's the
only condition.
Think like a Marxist.
You move some wealth around. The world
hasn't ended.
Move on. Nothing in valuation is worth
losing sleep over.
So, if you have this big deal about
effective tax rates, you want to use a
Go ahead and do it. It's not going to
alter the the entire universe. You might
lose a little money or somebody else
will make a little more money.
No, I'm not going to fight fights on
valuation because you feel strongly
about a metric.
And finally, if you're ever given a
choice between being lucky and knowing
everything there is know about
valuation,
which do you think matters more in
investing?
If you're lucky,
all is forgiven.
You can use EBIT as from now till the
cows come home, and you're going to make
a lot of money. If you're not,
you're done.
You can do everything right and have
nothing to show for it.
This is not something we're supposed to
tell people in business school, right?
Cuz you spend two year two years and
$200,000 being told what? If you learn
all these skills, you don't need luck.
You're just going to
That's a complete lie.
I mean, it was brought home to me my by
my mother-in-law when she came to visit
in early 2000.
And to give you some background,
my mother-in-law should never be allowed
to invest.
But during the '90s, she invested. She
made a lot of money. She showed up at
our home, and all day long, she would
watch the financial I I don't know
whether it was CNBC. All day It was like
a spectator sport for her. Every time
one of her stocks would go on the
tickers, they'd go, "Cisco, go."
Convinced it was actually pushing Look,
I pushed it up another 3 cents.
And all day long, all she would talk
about what was in her portfolio, what
was out of her portfolio, what she
wished was in her portfolio, what she
wished was out of her portfolio. And I'd
act like I was listening. That's what
sons-in-law must do.
And then she let it slip that she owned
Qualcomm, one of the great stocks of
1999. Up 600%.
I asked her, "Judy, why did you pick
Qualcomm?" I knew the minute I asked
this question I shouldn't have because
she told me.
She said she liked Qualcomm because it
owned MCI. I said, "That's not Qualcomm,
that's WorldCom."
She said, "Qualcomm, WorldCom, what's
the difference?" I said, "You bought the
wrong company."
If you'd actually bought WorldCom, it'd
have been down 30%. So, you buy some
other company that rhymes with it, and
you make 600%. I was afraid to ask her
after that why she owned Cisco, where
the answer would be that she likes
Saturday Night Live, which is Disco, or
you know, vegetable oil, which is
Crisco. Who knows?
But after she left, I did try a strategy
out, which is pick a company in the
news, pick one that rhymes with it.
Buy it. If I made a lot of money, this
entire class would have been about
rhyming stocks, right? Pick this one if
this one goes up.
Unfortunately, it did not.
So, if you're superstitious,
you notice that you go to a Starbucks at
a particular time, and you get that same
your portfolio seems to go up that day,
don't mess with it.
Keep doing it, right? This is not So, I
have I have acquired all this tolerance
for all these superstitious things that
you see, especially the context of
Indian businesses where you know, you've
got to have the right time you open the
business. You got to pray to the right
gods. You got to You know, roll around
temples. And You know what? If it works
for you for me, I'll buy Palantir. No,
I'll go roll around a temple. I'll do it
at the right time. If it works for you,
you should. So, if I have a parting wish
for you, be lucky, all right? Because
that If you're lucky, everything else
gets forgiven. Final points, one is
remember to do your CFAs.
And this is completely selfish on my
part.
Cuz you don't do You know what the CFAs
are, right? It's a course evaluation, so
make sure you finish those. Cuz if you
don't finish those,
what will you not be able to check?
Your grade. And then if you're not able
to find your grade, I know exactly
what's going to happen,
which is you're going to email somebody,
probably me, saying, "I can't see my
grade. Can you tell me what it is?" I
don't want to deal with that. I'm done
after next week, so
go out and do your course evaluations. I
think you're If you're open till
Thursday or Friday, I don't know what
what day it is. Get it done soon. Get it
out of the way, right?
You're You're You're And also make sure
you go to that final exam page and
specify I think about a third of the
class,
maybe half the class is taking it on
Thursday.
Right? I'm going to keep it online
because there are only about 12 people
who are going to be in New York, and I
don't think it's worth bringing you
those 12 into a classroom. So, those of
you taking it May 8th online, it'll be
on Brightspace.
You'll be taking the entire You need
internet connection all the way through.
It's not going to be like you're going
to download the exam. So, make sure
you're in a space. You know, this
morning somebody said, "I'm going to be
in Penn Station. Can I take the exam
there?" I said, "You can do it wherever
you want, but I can't think of a quiet
spot in Penn Station to take an exam for
2 hours." So, find a nice quiet spot for
you to take it. You know, and of course,
the regular exam is May 14th. The other
half of you are taking it then. And that
will be if you're in New York, I'd like
you to be in person because we're going
to You can take the exam here. But if
you're not in New York, obviously,
you're going to take it from somewhere
else. So, let me know what the end game
here is because I need to kind of figure
out the logistics. But that's it. Any
questions? I would like to ask a
question, but not about the logistics.
All right.
Why do you think was the reason most of
the class find most of the stocks
overvalued?
How is the market What has the market
done for the last few years?
Right? You have a market that's up 50,
60, 70% over a 4-year
You're going to be far more likely to
find things to be overvalued. It's not
due to the nature of the company's
valuation. No, because this shifts over
time, right? I
In 2022, in fact, more companies were
undervalued than overvalued, right after
that correction. It's just a question of
where the market is at the point in
time.
about the timing, not about the market.
Exactly.
Okay, that's it. I will see you at the
exam, or I'll see you online. Take care.
last week